okay welcome back everyone all right
two more lectures left in the entire
class I think everybody saw there was a
correction on homework six so I
apologize for any wasted hours trying to
solve an unsolvable problem but it
should be simpler now I'm really glad
this wasn't a final and was just a
take-home homework okay so today we're
gonna continue talking about the
singular value decomposition and we're
gonna look more at how to do essentially
curve fitting and looking at high
dimensional data sets with the the
singular value decomposition and then on
Friday the final lecture we're going to
build machine learning image
classification software in our computer
so we're going to train our computer how
to tell the difference between two
people using the singular value
decomposition any questions about the
SVD from last lecture or anything we've
talked about so far
okay good so one of the things we're
gonna do now is talk about the
pseudo-inverse
and least square solutions to matrix
systems of equations
okay so SVD and the pseudo-inverse
okay so let's say that I have a matrix
system of equations like a x equals B
okay we see these all the time
in linear algebra we have some matrix a
that we know we have some vector B of
measurements that we know and we want to
solve for X the unknowns and this could
be a system of equations to determine
the forces in every element of a bridge
truss for example or lots and lots of
other examples it could be a discretized
laplacian B could be some forcing and X
would be the vector potential okay so if
a is a square matrix which means that I
have as many measurements as I have
unknowns then you can just invert a and
solve for X as long as a is invertible
right as long as it's determinant is
nonzero
but what if a is not a square matrix
what if a is either a tall skinny matrix
or a is short squat matrix then what are
our options okay so you go first yeah so
let's take the first example where I
have I like drawing these with actual
shapes because it helps me think about
what's happening so let's say that I
have a tall skinny a matrix which means
that my X vector has to be small it has
to be the width of a so X is kind of a
short vector of unknowns and this equals
a really really tall vector of
measurements B so what can you say
generally speaking about the solutions
acts to the system of equations they're
gonna be solutions is there one solution
are there many solutions what can you
say about what's likely to happen with
this the solution X
okay so we call this overdetermined
meaning I have way too many measurements
and typically there is no solution X
that satisfies all of these equations
simultaneously right every row of this
is an equation and I have way more
equations than unknown unknowns and it's
very likely that some of these equations
will conflict with each other and
they'll just be fighting and you can't
find an exit satisfy as both of them
simultaneously so in general we're
unlikely to have a solution X in what
cases might I have a unique solution to
X for this system of equations
the rank of a is low which means that a
lot of rows of a and B are linearly
dependent so if I had a lot of duplicate
rows of a and B that would be fine or if
I had you know combinations of earlier
rows down here and combinations of
earlier B is down here that would also
be fine and then maybe my multiple rows
of a aren't fighting with each other and
I'll have a unique solution that's
possible but if I just randomly sample a
big a matrix if I just fill it with Rams
and I fill be with Rams there's
basically no chance I'll ever find a
unique solution X ok ok so this is case
one and case two is the other example
the short squat case of a or I have a
super tall row vector column vector X
really squat a and now my measurement
vector has to be short so in general
what can I say about the solution X for
this system of equations
okay lots more unknowns than there are
equations so we called this
underdetermined there's not enough
information to determine the solution
and what do we say about this
underdetermined system what's likely so
let's say I'd randomly populate a with
values and I randomly populate B with
values what's likely to be true of X
yes I'll definitely be able to find at
least one solution there should be a
solution because if I randomly make a
it's very unlikely that the rows will be
linearly dependent so there will
definitely be at least one X but it's
actually likely that there will be
infinitely many X's right I have all of
these degrees of freedom and X that have
no bearing on the relationship between a
and B so it's very likely that I'll have
infinitely many X's now what are some
counter examples what would be a case
where I would have no solution stacks
these are just general guidelines
they're not always true sometimes I'll
have infinitely many solutions to an
over determined system sometimes I'll
have no solutions to an underdetermined
system when might I have no solutions to
this system
let's say that I do an example and I
have X is the ages of Jack Ben and Molly
and let's say that I let's say that
Jack's age plus Ben's age plus Molly's
age equals 55 and let's then say that
Jack's age to Jack's age plus to Ben's
age plus to Molly's age equals 20 right
so I have linearly dependent rows of a
and I have completely inconsistent
measurements of B so I could cook up a
stupid example where I just make this
break there's no solutions to this
underdetermined system okay and you can
have similar examples here where I just
take the same row equation and I repeat
a bajillion times and I have infinitely
many solutions that's totally fine too
okay so these are just general
guidelines of what might happen in these
cases so this is all we're doing now is
talking about what types of solutions
there will be but I haven't told you how
to solve it how would I actually okay so
this is a bad example how would I
actually solve for the X in either of
these two examples if a was square we
would just invert a okay so let's take
the singular value decomposition of a
let's write a equals u Sigma V Star so
in the case of a tall skinny a we have a
equals now a now U is big square matrix
Sigma is the same size as a and V Star
is a little square matrix the width of a
okay so I have a is the product of these
three matrices and we have a x equals B
so what I can start doing is I can start
inverting each of these pieces okay
I can start inverting each of these
pieces and I can essentially say that X
is approximately equal so the first
thing I'm going to do is invert you and
what's the inverse of U u transpose
okay so I have let's let's just write
this out we have u Sigma V Star x equals
B and so I'm just gonna left multiplied
by U star and I get Sigma V star X is
about equal to I'm gonna write
approximate because there's some things
that are happening here U star B so I
multiply both sides by U star and I get
an identity here okay then I can
multiply both sides by Sigma inverse now
Sigma is not a square matrix so I'll
tell you what Sigma inverse means in a
minute so I get V Star X Sigma inverse u
star B and then finally this V Star is a
square matrix the inverse is just V and
so X is about equal to V Sigma inverse u
star B okay and so this thing is called
the pseudo inverse of a it looks like
the singular value of decomposition of a
where everything has flipped and
transposed and inverted okay so I lost
over a super important step here how do
I invert Sigma I can't really invert
Sigma right okay so there's a really
important thing that is happening here
so this a is really equal to I'm gonna
call this u R where R is the rank of a
how many linearly dependent rows and
columns a has followed by some other
stuff I'm gonna say it's perpendicular
and I don't care about it
and then I'm going to have some square
may
sigma r an r by r square matrix and
zeros everywhere else and then i'm going
to have V R star let's say that this a
has full column rank so the number of
columns is equal to R so basically what
I can do is I say that I can break this
you into the first part that multiplies
my nonzero singular values times my
nonzero right singular vectors V and
then everything else is multiplied by
this big 0 matrix so this equals u R
Sigma R VR star a is exactly equal to
just these first our columns times the
first R by our singular values times the
first R by our singular vectors V this
make sense right you have this big 0
chunk in the middle of Sigma and so
everything that multiplies that is just
cancels out
okay good and so really all of these are
have ours in them okay and now this
Sigma R really is a square matrix that I
can invert so every step here is fine
this you are transpose this you are is
not a square matrix but I can still take
the transpose and I can still multiply
it by B and I can still take the
transpose and I can multiply it on the
left of you are and I still get an r by
r identity because the first our columns
are orthogonal to each other okay so
anyway this is how I do this pseudo
inverse this is really really really
important this is the pseudo inverse and
the great thing is that it actually
solves for X for every single possible
combination that I've told you about it
solves for the over determined case
where I have one solution or no
solutions or infinitely many solutions
it also solves in the under determinant
case where I have no solutions one
solution or infinitely many solutions so
regardless of how many solutions X has
regardless of the shape of a I can
always do this pseudo inverse and get
something that approximates this X that
that approximates the best X for this
matrix system of equations so I'm going
to tell you what I mean by best X now
questions about this before I go on a
little bit hairy math you should really
write these things out in the in the
pages that I've included for the lecture
notes actually have pictures really
illustrating exactly what the shapes of
these are yeah
if a is not a full rank matrix then you
still have the first our columns so our
would be the rank of a and then I would
really have something that's like this I
would have Sigma R with some zeros there
would be some zeros to the right and
below and then I would have V R star and
then V everything else star so I would
also break V into its first are columns
and throw away everything else so in
general if the rank of so a it might
have rank one and then it would be one
column one number one column transposed
make us a one row so this is super super
powerful if I have a non-square matrix I
can approximate its inverse or something
like it's inverse it's a pseudo inverse
and I can solve matrix systems of
equations that might have no solutions
infinitely many solutions or one
solution and the solution that I get is
what's called an optimal solution it's
optimal in the sense that it's either
minimizes the error between ax and B or
it minimizes the length of the vector X
that you get out okay so how do we say
this if there are no solutions if there
are no exact solutions to ax equals B
and remember I can have cases where
there's no exact solutions to this for
both an overdetermined and
underdetermined but it's much more
likely for overdetermined systems not to
have a solution then X approximately
equal to VR Sigma R inverse u R
transpose B minimizes the norm
the norm error so it minimizes a X minus
D which is just a vector of the same
length as B it minimizes the two norm of
that vector and what is the two norm of
an error vector it's just the sum of the
squares of all the terms so it's the
mean square error so this minimizes this
is called a least squares solution
because it minimizes the mean squared
error so in that example where I had my
matrix 1 1 1 2 2 2 times x equals 55 and
20 where this was totally inconsistent I
can find the best possible X that gets
the closest to satisfying both of these
rows rows all right like I'm gonna have
some X and it's going to do the best it
possibly can it's satisfying both of
these rows and that solution with the
pseudo inverse gives me the single best
possible X that minimizes the error of
this system of equations that are
inconsistent okay so if I have noisy
data my nosy data might be like there's
not an exact x that'll fit my noisy data
because the noise is confounding
everything but I can find the best X
that minimizes the error between all of
my measurements I guess this is a least
squared or minimum error norm in the
other case so this is again kind of case
one in the other case let's say if
infinitely many solutions and there's
usually infinitely many solutions if I
have a massively underdetermined system
so a really short fat a matrix really
really tall X and a few measurements B
so if I
infinitely many solutions to ax equals B
then the pseudo-inverse solution and I'm
just going to there's a symbol for this
we say x equals a dagger not the
transpose it's a dagger it's awesome so
x equals a dagger b the pseudo inverse
of a times b minimizes the length of x
which is the 2 norm of x so the length
of any vector right the length of a 3
vector is the square root of x squared
plus y squared plus Z squared that's
what this two norm does it minimizes the
length of my vector X and so this is
called a minimum norm solution so even
if there's infinitely many possible X's
that solved my system of equations this
might be the best one because it's kind
of this short ax it's the least effort X
that gets me a solution it's the least
number of values maybe maybe this system
of equations is a times x equals B and
maybe X is a history of how I can spend
gas to get from you know here to
California and there's lots of different
ways I can accelerate so there's a ton
of possible X's and the minimum norm X
would be the most fuel economic way of
getting to California so a short X is
often a really good thing
short x means a lot like less energy
spent some times so the pseudo-inverse
is incredibly powerful oftentimes we
have systems of equations ax equals b
where there's either no exact solutions
cuz there's noise you know there might
be plus noise or there might be
infinitely many solutions because I
don't have enough measurements and in
either case the pseudo-inverse is giving
me an optimal solution in a way that
makes physical sense it's either
minimizing the error or it's minimizing
the norm of X
okay so let's do a really concrete
example here
so the simplest example is the following
okay
okay so let's say that a and B just
gonna make this lowercase because
they're these are scalars let's say that
a and B are my axes and I collect a lot
of data a lot of noisy data okay you
could say that a is time in years and B
is tree-ring diameter in doesn't matter
what units meters okay so for example I
can collect a ton of data I can go
unfortunately
I might have to chop down a lot of trees
to get all this data but I can go sample
a forest and I can measure you know how
many rings it has so a was like number
of rings or a number of years and B
would be the diameter of the tree how
big is it and there should be a pretty
strong correlation between the age of
the tree and the size of the tree the
width of it right so what I might want
to do is find a model a x equals B where
X relates the age of the tree to the
width of the tree and I want to find the
best slope x2 this line makes sense so I
have a bunch of pairs of points a 1
comma B 1 a 2 comma B 2 a 3 comma B 3 4
B 4 etc etc and I can stack these as a
big matrix a times a single number X
this is like the most degenerate case
equals
a big vector B and I want to find the
single best possible value X that
matches all of this data as well as
possible and of course there is no X
that exactly solves all this data right
because there's error in almost every
single one of these points but I'm gonna
find the X that minimizes the error of
this line to the entire fit makes sense
this is how we use the SVD one of the
main ways that we use the SVD is for
things like this you could do this in
multiple dimensions if there were other
factors a two and A three and a four
like maybe it wasn't just time but it
was annual rainfall and Sun activity you
could have all of these factors that
might correlate even better with tree
diameter and you could do the exact same
thing with a singular value
decomposition okay questions about the
problem formulation before we code it up
you have many factors that you're
considering that increases the
dimensionality of the problem okay I
have multiple factors like not just age
but I also had time then I could have a
one column which is time and a two
column which is rainfall and then I
would have x1 and x2 and I would still
be solving a massively underdetermined
system there would still be error in
every row but now I have two unknowns
how do these you know how does the tree
ring diameter jointly relate to both and
you like number of inches of rain and
the tree age okay and I could add as
many factors as I want and I could try
to get a better and better a better
model and at some point I might even
have more factors than I have
measurements and then it becomes a
minimum norm solution I want to find the
most important factors okay good good
question
all right so this is the basic
formulation I have a slope 3 I've just
made this slope up I'm going to cook up
some data a from minus 2 to 2 in
increments of 0.25 and I'm gonna
transpose it to make it a big column
vector then I'm going to take B equals
ax plus some noise some a lot of noise 1
times R and N and I'm gonna plot that
against also the true solution okay so
let's put in a legend here legend what
is this a true slope and noisy data and
this is what my data looks like ok makes
sense so the X line is my truth data
this is the underlying fundamental truth
of the data that I've cooked up and then
I have Gaussian noise on top of this and
what we're gonna do is we're gonna act
like we don't know what this black line
is we're only going to look at the red
points and we're gonna try to make our
new blue line which is the least squared
solution okay and the way we're gonna do
it is the following we're gonna take the
SVD of a super simple I'm doing what's
called an economy SVD because if you
ever do the SVD on a really a symmetric
matrix oh really tall or a really wide
matrix then you should do an economy
because it's faster and then I'm gonna
say that X tilde my best my least square
solution for X is V times the inverse of
s times u transpose and the economy is
nice it's only gonna give me the columns
that I want remember how we broke it
down into you are Sigma R V R star the
economy SVD is gonna do that for me it's
going to throw away all of the no rank
stuff ok good so now I have u Sigma and
V and the sizes are what we think they
should be they're just all you know you
as a single column vector
V is just a number and Sigma is just a
number because this is a rank one system
a is a single column okay and now if I
want to plot what my best model fit for
the system is it's just x tilde times a
it's just all of this stuff times a is
my best model fit for the tree-ring data
should probably run it all at once and
you can see it's not perfect but if you
didn't have the black line at all this
blue line would be better than nothing
right okay how would I make my data how
would I make my fit better increase the
number of measurements what's another
way sorry so I could over fit actually I
could make a quadratic line I could make
a xx order polynomial that hits every
single one of these points right I could
over fit that's a really tricky tricky
issue let's just say that I increase the
number of points so instead of 0.25 I go
down to 0.1 and I run the same thing
again with you know 2.5 times more data
now my blue and my black lines are
almost on top of each other so
essentially we're averaging out all of
this noise with the singular value
decomposition we're filtering our
solution and we're getting a better and
better fit the more data we have okay
makes sense now in that lab there's a
nice easy built-in command called PN so
you don't ever have to type in you know
V times invest times u transpose you
could just type pn of a probably that
should work that also works but i just
wanted to show you that this really is
exactly the same as the pseudo-inverse
there's another way i could do a
backslash B that also works I think
sure that works too so lots of ways to
do this in a lab okay questions about
this this simple example before we go on
to something more sophisticated okay
good
so now what we're gonna look at is
cancer data actually maybe I should do I
might only have time to do the cancer
data okay I'll do cancer data first and
then I'll come back to the very exciting
world of cement mixing it's one of the
one of the funner examples we have it
really is actually quite interesting
okay so let's do let's do the ovarian
cancer data set so what we're going to
look at is the following
now I can't remember the exact size of
everything because these are built-in
data sets in MATLAB so MATLAB has a lot
of great built-in data sets you can
google MATLAB built-in data sets and
you'll find a list of about 20 of them
so they have the classic cars data set
ovarian cancer ionosphere measurements
cement mixtures like all of these
classical data sets where you can try
out these methods on them and so the
ovarian cancer data set is an example of
how we use this SVD for principal
components analysis PCA and nowadays the
SPD and the PCA in my mind are kind of
synonymous they do the same basic thing
but PCA goes way back over a hundred
years this is a statistical method to
find the correlations in high
dimensional data okay so the example I
gave you as three rings is actually not
too far off there would be an example
where they would go look at clams and
they would measure every day
mention of the clam the mass the length
the height the width the size of the
tongue like all did measure 10 things
and they would also have some proxy
measure for age in some cases they would
actually know this and they would try to
build a model from those factors to the
age okay in principle components
analysis is one of the ways you do that
basically the principal components
analysis takes a big data matrix X and
it tries to find the dominant
correlations in X just like the SVD does
so if I take the SVD of X I get the
principal components analysis but
usually what I do is I subtract out the
mean of X first and I divide by the
variance of every row so let me give you
an example differences the major
differences between SVD and PCA so I
told you that in X icepack my
measurements as big columns right so for
example if I sampled the blood from
everyone in this room which would be
creepy I could find what your gene
expression were for like 4,000 genes and
I would have a 4,000 by 50 matrix okay
in principal components analysis we
would stack those measurements as rows
so like the big measurements that
correspond to one individual those are
now rows
so now my ex is going to look like my
measurement one this is all of the genes
for person one all of the genes for
person two up to all of the genes for
person 50 so this would be like a 50 by
40,000 matrix
super simple difference all I'm doing is
transposing it okay
and so my singular value decomposition
in this case x equals you Sigma V Star
now the things I care about the
correlations between gene expression are
now coded up in the columns of V which
are the rows of V star okay so rows of V
Star play the same role take the same
role in PCA as columns of u before so
it's just a total I mean it's like if
you went to a different country and they
buttered their toast butter side down
okay it's exactly the same except they
transpose their matrix first make sense
nothing else changes these guys got here
first also so where the dissenters okay
and usually we would subtract out the
mean and we would divide by the variance
of each row so that they were all kind
of unit variance so maybe if one person
just had more gene expression everywhere
across the board I would bring us all
down to the same level okay because I
want to look at the relative differences
between gene one and gene fifty etcetera
etc and I want an apples-to-apples
comparison so maybe you just have more
gene expression than I do on this day
for some reason maybe not at breakfast
and I didn't okay I did eat breakfast
all right so this is what our data is
gonna look like and then what we're
going to have is essentially for every
person we're going to have a label of
whether they do or do not have ovarian
cancer
it would make sense if these were all
women but they might not be I don't know
so I would have labels for all of these
people about if there is or is not
ovarian cancer and then I can
essentially look at the gene expressions
for each of these people so what I want
to do is I want to look at the three
most dominant modes and what are my
modes that I'm talking about I ghen
vectors of X star X so they're either
columns of U or columns of V depending
on how I stack my data so the three most
dominant modes I think in this case
there are three first columns V and then
I want to look at how each of the people
what their expression is in those
columns so in MATLAB I can take V colon
the entire column of V one two three the
whole first three columns of V and let's
let's just say that these are columns of
U because I know how to do this for you
let's say that I have columns of U and I
stack my data like a normal person
I could take that transpose times X and
what I would get are coefficients I
would get three numbers for each person
so for you I would get your alpha 1
alpha 2 alpha 3 which tells me how much
of modes 1 2 & 3 you have versus you and
you and you we would all have our own
alpha 1 2 & 3 mixture and maybe people
with ovarian cancer have a fundamentally
different alpha mixture than people
without ovarian cancer that's the
hypothesis okay okay questions before I
code this up
standard deviation taking the STD book
with it in the SVD might be the variance
I don't know it doesn't it shouldn't
matter a lot okay
well because I'm trying to make this
thing unit variance which would also
have unit standard deviation so it
shouldn't matter okay all right let's
just jump in then I honestly can't
remember in my data set if I stack it
like PCA or like SVD so we'll find out
okay so I told you that some of these
are built into MATLAB which is great so
ovarian cancer is just already pre-built
into MATLAB you can just say load
ovarian cancer and what I get are a big
matrix called observations and this is
two hundred and sixteen by four thousand
so this is the PCA way of stacking
things I have two hundred and sixteen
patients four thousand genes per
patients they're stacked in rows okay
all of the genes are stacked in rows and
group is a set of labels which tells me
which group they belong to so let's just
look at group if I just type in group I
have a bunch of normal and a bunch of
cancer so I have labels for every single
patient so the first you know one
hundred and thirteen might be in a
cancer group and the other ones are in
the normal group and so I can color
these different patients based on their
category it's a really nice data set
this is real data okay so I take the SVD
and what am I gonna do so I take the SVD
it takes a while and now what I'm going
to look at or what are my distributions
of singular values right so I always
want to look at the diagonal elements of
Sigma to see how dominant are the first
modes that I'm going to be using how
important are they and I see that my
first mode captures about 55 percent of
the variants in the data set that's
great that means everyone in this room
shares about 55 percent of the same you
know the same mixture describes all of
the data and then you know or different
levels of that first mode will explain
the differences in all of our data and
then the next mode picks up another you
know 6 or 7 percent then another couple
percent and the cumulative variance of
the first three modes is about 64
percent which is good that's actually
really not bad that means I can explain
a lot of the variants in our data just
from the first three modes it would be
kind of disappointing if these were way
down in the 5 or 10% that would mean
that there's a
lot of stuff that we're not getting with
the first few modes okay now what I'm
gonna do is for every single patient for
every row of our observation I'm gonna
multiply it by the corresponding column
the first the first column of V the
second column of V in the third column
of B so I'm going to get the alpha 1
alpha 2 alpha 3 coefficients for every
single person in my deck in my
observation deck and if they're the
cancer group I'm going to make a red X
and if they're the healthy non-cancer
group I'm going to make a blue circle
okay should probably label X let's try
an X label this is PCA 1 Y label is PCA
2 z label is PCA 3 and do I have should
probably put a legend on two that's very
likely that the legends gonna bomb out
so cancer is red and you see here that
there's actually a beautiful separation
I mean it's not perfect in the first
three modes but I clearly have clusters
of cancer and not cancer and you could
even imagine that there's a pretty darn
good line I could draw through these
where I might get 80% diagnostic
capability right so if you come into the
doctor's office they run a simple test
they take the dot product of your gene
expression with PCA modes 1 2 & 3 and
then if you're way over in the center of
the blue region you probably are okay
and if you're way over in the center of
the red region they should probably do
more tests for cancer because it's
likely that you have ovarian cancer okay
super fast sheep pretty good Diagnostics
based on principal components analysis
now how would I do a better separation
between these two categories increase
the number of modes so if I look at just
PCA 2 & 3 that's actually there's more
mixing between them right and when I
look at just
ca1 and three there's also a lot of
mixing but when I get all of the modes
together that's when I start seeing a
pretty clean separation and so maybe if
I add PC a four five and six they would
actually really separate a lot more in
those dimensions maybe I would really be
able to draw a line and get 99%
categorization and it turns out that you
can do exceedingly well at telling
diseases apart just from these low
dimensional representation of gene
expressions and things like that what
other things could I do to make this
better
what other what other analyses could I
use to make this data better
yes I could try to apply machine
learning to these three numbers to my
alpha numbers and I could try to find
better ways of separating them I could
also add more data I can add demographic
data I could say well what is the age
race and diet of these people right
there are biases in cancer based on age
race and diet and other habits like
smoking non-smoking things like that
like maybe your gene expressions are
different because you're a vegan maybe
your gene expressions are different
because you only eat meat right maybe
you gene expressions are different
because you're a smoker maybe a lot of
this variance can be explained by meta
data that would actually bring these a
lot more into clusters that would be
okay well I have my my carnivorous
normal and my carnivorous cancer and my
smoking you know 30 under 35 normal and
my smoking under 35 cancer and I could
add more data that would give me more
features to separate yeah in the
original data set would they go on the
end of the gene expression so there's a
few ways you could do it I could tack on
metadata and I could even weight it more
heavily in my X matrix that's one way to
do it that's not how I would do it I
mean I would just do a hierarchical
classification where I would I would
color these things now instead of X's
that are red and circles that are blue I
might have you know maybe smokers and
non-smokers are the circles in the x's
and maybe normal and cancer are blue and
red so now I have four types of markers
and whenever I get a diagnostic for a
person I first ask you the metadata and
that trickles down this you know tree
and I look at a much more restricted set
of people's gene expressions and I get a
much better idea of what is your gene
expression normal for your type of
demographics for your meta data so
there's lots and lots and lots of ways
to do this I could also feed that into
the machine learning algorithm so when I
give the machine learning algorithm is
alpha 1 alpha 2 alpha 3 age race you
know gender and all you know all of the
metadata so I could augment my features
with that metadata there's whole
classes on this type of dimensionality
reduction and there's whole classes on
this type of machine learning there are
dozens hundreds of methods to learn from
this data how to best classify things
like this could be people that will pay
money in a video game and people who
won't write like let's say you're
playing some phone game and they want to
get you to spend $0.99 a bunch of times
there are people that will pay easily
and often and there will people who will
never pay no matter how painful it is
and you might want a machine learn those
people and I might even want to force
these people into the paying category if
I like have some control mechanism okay
I might want to manipulate people that's
how Amazon and Walmart and everyone who
makes money works okay they break people
into demographics based on features
these used to be determined by experts
right a bunch of people would get in a
room and experts would say okay well you
have different categories of people and
those different categories like whiskey
and cigars and other categories like you
know different things and then they
would target the advertising and the
purchasing to the different people based
on expert knowledge this is just a way
of mining that knowledge from existing
data ok tons of stuff you can do with
this it's really limitless there are
limits there's big limits but there are
a ton of opportunities for this type of
data analysis so the last example I'll
show you on Friday is how to use this
kind of dimensionality reduction to take
very very very high dimensional data
like jeans or like all of the pixels and
a megapixel image of a face and actually
build one of these machine learning
setups to tell the difference between
two different types of people so the
last example we'll do kind of our
Facebook icon faces example okay thank
you